fun fact auditioning is my least
favorite part of being an actress
[Music]
yeah i'm sure there's footage of me
bombing on auditions but i blocked it
out of my mind never to be heard from
racine again i went into the audition
and i just knew i had it and i was like
here it is
and as i was going to start it she said
stop that
do less i'll say what do you want me to
do nothing and then she says exactly
one of the auditors was eating a
meatball son
during my audition and i stopped this
dude's eating a meatball sub during my
performance also i was hungry because i
don't eat when i'm nervous
i love dogs just not in my audition you
know and this dog is like coming towards
me it was one of those dogs that kind of
waddled and i see it at the corner of my
eye and i'm trying to ignore it and stay
in character because that's what good
actors do put him outside the room
i got a call at the chemistry read would
be like 7 p.m i was like oh this is
weird and it was literally like the
bachelorette we would go into the room
we would audition but then some people
would go to this other room and then
some people would be sent home and then
some people would go back to the waiting
room and it was like you get a rose you
don't need a roof and the brand knew i
got it that i was just the last person
in the room i got the rose
[Music]
you